What are you not telling me?
The future has changed, I saw Savitar murder you.
we need to figure out everything that happens leading up to Iris' death
if we can change one of these events, we can change them all.
I swear I will protect you
Iris needs a Hero right now Wally, we can prove that we can alter the future here and now
get ready McFly, we're about to vibe you back to the future
3...2...1...
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie, happy holidays.
New flash footage lets break it down future
flash causing all kinds of problems.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything.
So what's going on in this is that they're
basically trying to go back to that moment,
that they saw Iris West killed but Wally is
going along this time they're going to try
and stop savitar two on one.
Maybe they can finally defeat him, but the
problem with that it's a if you learn anything
from previous seasons on the flash is that
when you try to change the future time finds
a way of replacing that thing that you are
trying to stop with something that even worse
or equally as bad your stressing temporal
reversion how long day changes like I'm living
it all over again is not too much you could
stop this, no I mean I was running faster
than I ever read.
The first is to some really horrible things
happening was at Hideaway not to me.
I don't know anything about the future you
experience nothing to wellsite Barry time
is an extremely fragile construct any matter
how small could result in a cataclysmic here's
what you going to do everything you did before
every word you uttered every step you took
they're going to do it again and you're not
going to tell anyone.
So even if they were able to stop savitar
in the future from killing Iris West.
Somebody else would probably end up dying.
Like maybe Wally will end up dying.
So you really just trading Iris for somebody
else on team flash.
You also see Caitlin snow's killer Frost I.
So it seems like she's getting worse and worse.
She took those bracelets off during Christmas
like all hey let's make it's noticeably nice.
Every time she uses her powers she becomes
a little bit more of that killer Frost persona.
The other big thing not quite so dire Iris
and Barry in bed together just getting it
on.
So they're finally doing all the things it
looks like based on Iris's reaction he finally
comes clean.
But one of the big problems that he's had
this past season is in keeping secrets like
this of this magnitude from his friends.
Usually that winds up hurting them more than
it helps like the big lesson of flashpoint
is that Barry is not allowed to change time.
It just doesn't work that way he winds up
making things worse when he tries to change
events that was what Jay Garrick's coffee
cup explainer was all about me kid this coffee
cup right here is the space back in time it
breaks you can reset and try to fix it matter
how hard you try.
So really the wrong lesson that Barry has
learned is that he can go back into the past,
to try and change the future but the whole
twist of this clip is that he tries to revive
into the future to change the future, so he's
like oh this is totally different seek I'm
going into the future.
I'm not going into the past there also back
in the time vault here, I know a lot of people
were wondering about that in season two what
happened to Gideon Gideon is sort of like
an all-encompassing AI kind of like Siri that
is now on the legends of tomorrow shipped
the WaveRider.
So the is the only reason that they're not
using on the flash is because they don't want
to do that on every single show all the time
so they still have access to the technology
that gives them this future newspaper, but
it seems kind of limited like they could look
at the newspaper and as they make changes
they can see how the newspaper changes, so
the way their setting this up in the back
half of the season is that Barry is going
to do anything to save Iris which usually
has a negative connotation like he's going
to cross the line the line the Jay Garrick
spelled out for him pretty clearly no change
time to do it only makes things worse.
So he's probably going to cross that line
and it's got a lead to the future flash message
that we heard on legends of tomorrow called
the choice that affect time on as you know
you also supposed changes affect the present
to compound in the future when you return
you in the new time.
Once future, including yours trust anything
more.
You may have also noticed Harrison wells here
looks way more hard-core.
That's probably because you know crazy here
here this is earth two Harrison wells because
earth.
19 Harrison wells, HR just does not seem.
This focus usually dancing around wearing
weird scars wearing glasses making jokes getting
people copy earth two Harrison wells the hard-core
Harrison wells is way less talkative and wears
way more playing close.
So this would seem to imply the Jesse quick
earth two Harrison wells have come back
while I'm gone never ever fall what was your
world what was in his school the I'm star.
So don't really confirm them anywhere in the
trailer but just based on the way Harrison
wells looks in this clip.
It just seems like it's earth two Harrison
wells we also see Wally and Barry versus plunder
there was that other trailer that I posted
where it's like right after this moment after
they taken in the prison, so this fills in
a lot of gaps.
So plunder is sort of like the villain of
the week even though he ties in with the serialized
savitar storyline remember.
When Barry went three months in the future
that's basically when this Iris moment is
happening.
They had the newscast with plunder being put
on trial.
So whatever it is he does it seems like he
has some interesting role to play in Barry
changing Iris's fate plunder himself has this
really hard-core gun.
So it looks like he's trying to pull a hit
on someone may be the flash himself will be
interesting to see who he goes after the killer
Frost teasers a little more straightforward
like Caitlin just slowly being forced to use
her powers to help her friends, but as a consequence
of that she slowly becomes more and more killer
Frost more and more evil turning against the
group.
So ironically, the thing that she called him
out for our killer Frost called about four
missing with their lives.
He's continuing to do in this clip the way
their setting it up is just to make him feel
more sympathetic because were trying to save
Iris's life.
So you have the whole team working here.
You have Cisco who's agreeing to vibe him
into the future.
Even though it's probably can end terribly.
So there messing with everyone's lives, but
it seems like there's more consent from the
rest of the group is not just Barry acting
by himself anymore.
You can let me know what you think is good
happened when they try and change the future
get clearly it's not gonna work, but what
you think the consequence is going to be like
the savitar kill someone else is this a self
fulfilling prophecy whereby the steps they
take to try and avoid this future is what
ends up causing it to happen in the first
place that's one of the big mine trips of
the flash is that through time travel his
life is kind of like this loop.
Like when he eventually dies and you do whatever
final season or future battle he ends up becoming
the bolt of lightning the gave him powers
sort of reuse starting the timeline.
So even though I think the flash is going
to run for a lot of seasons.
We might get teasers for that to I'm hoping
they do that storyline at some point where
flash becomes the bolt of lightning that originally
gave himself powers was originally doing a
video about future flash.
When this footage dropped.
So will happen is is in a couple days I'll
just finish that and post it, so I'll explain
that future Barry message was going on with
this darkest timeline Barry that just doing
everything he can to try and save Iris I've
also got a video for the flash prophecy which
gets in the more this killer Frost up like
someone eventually but train the team.
Someone falling from grace someone dying.
So there any other flash bonus videos you
guys want me to do during the break just let
me know in the comments below.
The way time.
Congratulations to this week's winner Freddie
tremble you win a flash ring please private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video.
I'll name the winner the next time I post
a DC video.
What's going to happen later tonight is I
have some new Rick and Morty season three
footage so I'll post that they'll also be
a giveaway for that there's like a really
cool Rick and Morty hardcover that they're
releasing.
So I'll be giving that away too look out for
that in a couple hours while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for that
other flash trailer and you can click here
for my breakdown of the Justice league teaser
they just dropped trailer coming really soon.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!